6-Mute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-Mute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Georgi and I'm Beth.
Mentionation is an issue that's not often talked about, yet every month it affects
billions of women around the world. Mentionation or periods are a natural process that typically
happen once a month, when women and girls bleed from their vagina for a few days as part of
the reproductive cycle. When this happens, women need special products like sanitary pads or tampons
to manage the flow of blood and go about their day-to-day life. Unfortunately, over 500 million
people around the world either don't have access to these products or can't afford to buy them,
and this is called period poverty. Period poverty has serious consequences. For example,
girls on their periods not going to school affects their education, and women who can't work during
their period have less income. What's more, it can cause health problems because without sanitary
products it's easy to get infections. In this programme we'll be learning about one project
fighting period poverty affecting thousands of women refugees, and of course we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well. But first Georgi, I have a question for you. Periods affect girls
and women of reproductive age. That's roughly half the female population or 26% of the global population,
but how many people is that? Is it a 2.1 billion people, b 2.3 billion people, or c 2.5 billion people?
I guess it's about 2.1 billion people. Okay Georgi, I will reveal the answer at the end of the programme.
Ella Lambert was a student at Bristol University when she started the Pacha Mama project in 2020
during the first Covid lockdown. She'd heard about period poverty and decided to put her lockdown
time to good use by making sanitary pads. Pieces of soft material used to absorb menstrual blood.
Here's Ella explaining how her project got started to BBC World Service programme people fixing
the world. So I borrowed a sewing machine from a friend, I learned how to sew on YouTube,
and then I just started making pads. And even now to this day I can't sew anything else, only pads.
Ella started making reusable sanitary pads, which aren't a new thing. They're made from
absorbent fabrics such as fleece and cotton sheets, which means that they can be used over and
over again after they're washed, unlike disposable pads. Ella spent lockdown learning how to sew,
how to join pieces of material by hand using a needle and thread or with a sewing machine.
In fact, Ella was so focused on sewing sanitary pads she didn't make anything else.
And to this day, pads are the only thing she knows how to sew. Ella uses the phrase to this day,
to say up to and including the present moment. Sanitary pads aren't easy to make. The outer layer
has to be soft because it touches the skin, but they also need to be absorbent, able to soak up
liquids like blood and hold them. What's more, Ella designed her pads to be washed and used again,
unlike most sanitary pads bought in shops, which are disposable, designed to be thrown away after
they've been used. Ella's network of volunteers sewing reusable sanitary pads grew. And to date,
the Pachamama project has donated tens of thousands of period products to refugees, fleeing
conflict in Syria, Turkey and Lebanon, as well as women here in the UK. Plus, the project is helping
in other ways too. Despite affecting so many people and being necessary for life itself, many
cultures consider menstruation unclean or shameful, not a topic of polite conversation, but
Ella thinks her project is giving refugees the confidence to talk about periods. As she told
BBC World Services, people fixing the world. I have seen such major change in such a short period
of time. Like the women originally who were distributing the pads were barely even speak about
it and we had it behind a curtain. And now they're chatted away about the pads with their male
colleagues, anyone that comes into the shop. Before, most women refugees would barely talk about
menstruation. They would only just scarcely talk about it. But now they're happily chatting away,
passing the time talking to other women and even to male colleagues. I think it's time I reveal
the answer to my question. As a number, how many women make up the 26% of the world's population
who menstruates? I said it was 2.1 billion people, which was the correct answer. Okay, let's recap the
vocabulary we've learned in this programme, starting with the verb to sew, to join material together
using a needle and thread, either by hand or with a sewing machine. The phrase to this day means up to
and including the present moment. The adjective absorbent means able to soak up and hold liquid,
and the adjective disposable means designed to be thrown away after use. If you barely do something,
you only just do it by the smallest amount. And finally, to chat away means to pass the time
by talking a lot with someone. Once again, our six minutes are up. We hope you'll join us again
next time here at six minute English. Bye for now. Bye!